Congress is back to work today and the
immediate focus in the house is on
immigration and the so-called dreamers
and the Senate may be doing a lot more
work than previously anticipated chief
congressional correspondent Mike Emanuel
has the story
greasing the skids or grinding to a halt
the Senate majority leader tells his
colleagues to buckle up for a long hot
summer and in the house a gang of
renegade moderates turns up the heat on
leadership Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell blasted Democrats for
obstruction I think we have enough work
to do with the American people that we
should be here during these weeks I hope
we'll get greater cooperation but
everybody should anticipate that we will
be here the Senate Democratic leader
suggested president Trump should stay in
town too we assume he'll be here in
Washington working right alongside us in
the house some GOP moderates are trying
to break up gridlock on immigration
two more Democrats signing on today so
organizers are just three short of the
218 signatures needed to force votes on
immigration bills June 25th as house
Republican leaders try to find a GOP
solution we're very close on a couple of
different fronts that really boil down
to how are we going to handle the doctor
recipients president Trump weighed in on
immigration first thing this morning on
Twitter separating families that the
border is the fault of bad legislation
passed by the Democrats border security
laws should be changed but the Dems
can't get their act together started the
wall Arizona Republican Senator Jeff
Flake says that isn't helpful I've
worked with Democrats honey regression
they don't want open borders they don't
favor ms-13 so I wish you wouldn't make
those accusations Attorney General Jeff
Sessions issued this warning to those
considering coming here illegally we
don't want to do this at all if people
don't want to be separated from their
children they should not bring them with
them that's we've got to get this
message out you're not given immunity
the acting head of Immigration and
Customs Enforcement offered this advice
to lawmakers if you wanted to a fix on
doctor let's talk about the overarching
issues of immigration and let's fix that
so we don't have a doc every 10 years it
is not clear that immigration would be
debated and voted on in August
since McConnell has said he's only
interested in taking up a bill president
trop would be willing to sign but
cutting short recess could have the
effect of forcing some cooperation on
legislation and nominees rep like
Emanuel love on the hill Mike thanks